we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192davidp
you can call anytime i am slowly going
through the 600 voicemails i have from
when i was away
um here is one that came in about a guy
whose friends
are going to
fake vaccine cards take a listen
hi david uh big fan of your show
i just found out
it's very heartbreaking that
two of my friends that i was close with
they both plan on getting fake coven
vaccine cards yeah and i tried to report
them to the local department of health
i'm not sure if i'm doing enough though
um so if i could get any insight on this
i'm kind of shaking because i was so
upset when i found out this morning it's
a disgusting thing to be doing so let's
let's talk about a few things first of
all is requiring vaccination a waste of
time if you can fake a vaccine card no
no system is foolproof no system is
foolproof but it's so easy to get
vaccinated i know you'll say a lot of
people don't want to get vaccinated for
political reasons and i get that
but it's so easy to get vaccinated it's
really easy for for most people it's
easier to get vaccinated than to figure
out how to put together a vaccine card
that you feel really would pass muster
that the whole point is let's just use
that to convince more people to go and
get vaccinated no system is foolproof i
mean i'll be honest to get back to the
united states from europe
i needed a negative test within 72 hours
of coming back
um and i i did one i got one i brought a
test with me that uh i connect with
someone it's called a telehealth
observation they watched me do the test
i put the drops in the thing they
verified that i did it correctly it
comes back negative they send me a pdf
i could have faked the pdf i mean it did
you know at frankfurt airport
it was
five seconds that they looked at it and
really all they looked at was does it
say negative
um
does it say my name
and is the date within three days i
could have been showing anything at all
are some people probably faking the
negative test yes but for enough people
it's difficult enough to know how do i
make a real you know a good looking pdf
is that i'll just go and get myself the
test any system is going to have some
people that get around it no system is
foolproof i don't think that's a reason
not to do it now
what essentially is being done when you
fake a cdc
vaccination record
is
you were using an official government
agency's seal
um
without authorization and that's a crime
okay so when people do that
there may be law written
to specifically go for faking
vaccination
but faking a cdc certificate is a crime
it can be punishable under title 18 us
code section 1017 and other laws so it
is a crime so you should report it if
you know of people that are doing this
this is really it's an attack on
humanity really because what you're
doing is you're endangering people and
the recommendation is you call 1-800 hhs
tips
or
you can go to ic3.gov that's for
internet crime i don't know if it's
exactly an internet crime but that's
another recommendation so 1 800 hhs tips
or
ic3.gov you can also uh contact
local law enforcement you can contact
your local district attorney attorney
general almost anyone should be able to
direct you as to what to do so not only
should we make it easier to just get
vaccinated than to fake a certificate
we should really be making examples out
of people that are caught faking the
certificates i've already read in fact
that because the card can be faked
that there's going to be a different
method and
electronic record maybe or whatever the
case may be we're going to have to wait
and see all
it's so great to be back we have a
fantastic bonus show uh producer pat
will defiantly and heroically rejoin me
on the award-winning world famous bonus
show i am going to talk to you about my
uh trip i'm going to talk to you about
positive covered test i have a story
from my trip that i'm calling positive
cova test
um and we will talk about so many other
things that are uh taking taking place
and things we missed during my break and
so on and so forth so get instant access
you go to joinpacman.com
you sign up
we did do a 16th anniversary special if
you missed the email and you want the
code
send an email to info davidpakman.com
you are not going to want to miss listen
i'll i'll give you i don't have coven
okay i don't have code but i'm going to
give you a story that is crazy involving
a positive coveted test over my trip so
sign up at joinpakman.com we'll speak to
you then we're here tomorrow i look
forward to taking some of your calls on
the friday show it's really great to be
back